this is breaking news on 8 news now
it is 6 30 and welcome to good day las
vegas everyone i'm alex beckett
i'm john langley good morning to you at
home we do start with the breaking news
metro police investigating
this issue situation in the southwest
valley officers shot and killed someone
about 1 30 this morning
yeah it happened in a gated neighborhood
near tropicana and durango bianca
holman's been there all morning for us
she joins us now live with the very
latest details hi bianca what can you
tell us
good morning john and alex well this
situation happened
in the spanish hills neighborhood and in
this neighborhood for those that are
familiar
they've got million dollar homes and you
can see police are still at the entrance
of this gated
community a 9-1-1 call and a home
security system alerted police to this
burglary that happened in earlier this
morning
we're told that there were two people in
the home when a man broke in
metro police briefed us on the details
once they arrived
as officers arrived on scene and
approached the house they could see the
suspect inside the house
officers made entry into the house and
immediately saw the suspect armed with a
hammer
attempting to attack the homeowner
officers fired their weapons and the
suspect was struck
a pretty scary situation for those two
people in that home
and when the ambulance arrived they
pronounced the suspect dead a man
at the scene the suspect was a man
excuse me and so this is actually the
18th officer involved shooting for 2020
no officers were injured at this time
and during that situation we are told
that the sheriff will be sharing that
body camera footage from those officers
that were involved
within the next 72 hours and also be
giving us a more detailed update on what
happened overnight
john alex so bianca since that
neighborhood
is gated do police know at this point
how that guy got into the neighborhood
alex right now details are very limited
it is a neighborhood that actually has a
guard at that gate
but they are not sure just yet how that
person or how that intruder and that man
got into the neighborhood so they don't
want to speculate anything as of right
now
interesting all right we will stand by
to learn more thank you bianca for
following that we appreciate it